happy 10th of november reject nation
we're gonna watch from the cosmic wonder
a breakdown video
not some rumor not any of those this is
a breakdown one division first episode
details
wanda becoming scarlet witch the ew full
breakdown that's
entertainment weekly for those
who are not in the no and it also can
sound like
ew this is great this is great i should
have eaten
i have no excuses for the terrible
openings
i'm so sorry for this the coverage isn't
that great let's
just watch this
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything mcu and today is a great
day because we have some
exclusive one division from
entertainment
there are a lot of reveals in this new
issue of entertainment weekly focusing
on one division
i don't be sure i don't get any money
photos for the one division series and a
lot of commentary about some of the
episodes of one division from kevin
feige elizabeth olsen
paul bettany and some of the writers and
producers as well
including some talk about how wanda is
going to fully transform into the
scarlet witch by the end of the series
and how the series is going to directly
lead into doctor strange and the
multiverse of a madness specifically the
scarlet witch will make her appearance
in the multiverse of madness
okay a lot of great information in this
article so if you don't have access to
it don't worry i've got you covered so
i'll break it all down but first i'm
doing a new
giveaway i'm partnered with
heroeshideout.com
and from now through december till the
end of the holidays i'll be giving away
one item each week from marvel funko
pops to marvel legends action figures
all you have to do to enter subscribe to
my channel like this video leave a
comment down below and check out
heroeshideout.com
so the first thing we'll dive into
before getting into some details about
the wanavision series and episodes that
they filmed
are new pictures now the first one that
we got is obviously the cover photo for
this
issue of entertainment weekly it has
wanda and vision on front of it and
wanda is half the title black and white
which we know the show is going to start
off in black and white and then
gradually become color as time goes by
just like over the years and the
after title the box office marvel is
ready to take over tv
here comes wanda vision now this is just
a cover photo but we do have
six new images from actual episodes of
the series and we'll start off with this
first one which is kind of odd
lucy and ricky odd which is awesome but
it's of wanda
and vision and as we can see here they
are sleeping in
separated beds now this is kind of done
for two reasons one is that with the old
sitcoms it was actually
they had to sleep in the same bed
decency
on tv now this kind of just further adds
to the weirdness of their relationship
but if you look at wanda she's looking a
little bit confused
now we know this is going to involve
different realities so it's almost like
one
that has a sleeping bag in this room
with vision
it's either that or she has noticed
something weird or she has heard
something and it doesn't all make sense
and if you take a look at the shadows on
the wall it's like a witch
it's like a witch hatchet
yeah of course this is just a shadow
from the bedpost but this is also
like a reference read into it we know
agatha hartness is involved and we know
that there's going to be witchcraft in
the show
and for those who might think this is
digging a little bit too deep marvel has
actually already done this with their
first promotional art for the one
division series if we take a look at the
two
oh you see them in the corner ah
you see it do you see you john
you can see in the upper left-hand
corner their shadows are of their
superhero forms we can see
vision as an android but who's in the
photograph which in her
full scarlet witch costume and speaking
of doesn't matter
after all agnes is just agatha and
harkness combined to make one word but
you'll also be playing the unusual nosy
neighbor and in this photo it looks like
she came over to give the couple a
pineapple or is it
one either way it's kind of weird now
the next photo is actually a very
important photo
baby pregnant now the important part of
this photo is one not only does it
confirm that wanda is going to be
pregnant and will indeed have kids
which has already been confirmed but the
second part is look at their faces they
both look to be an extreme confusement
and this is most likely because
wanda is going to randomly get pregnant
yeah in the comics it happens out of
nowhere
vision doesn't actually give wand a kid
she just becomes pregnant it's
impossible
because of the best consider the fact
that they're sleeping in separate beds
in the show
but they do that means they never do
never they can't get it
is going to be in the one division
series and he is the one responsible for
wanda getting pregnant this is a page
right out of the comics where wanda gets
impregnated by
magic and we would go on to find that
her two children are actually the shards
of the demon mephisto
and ultimately her children would be
gone and this is what eventually left
her kind of losing her mind and creating
the house of m
reality right neato ruled the world now
the rest of the photos are kind of just
fun photos there's one envision leaning
over the kitchen counter looking at each
other smiling you can tell that they're
really happy there's one envision inside
the kitchen again and wanda has a weird
expression on her face
perhaps performing some type of magic
and then the last one with a very
confused look on her face and she is
indeed performing magic
using her powers to peek it looks like
she's preparing dinner and something
like the witch
the show that gives us some pretty big
reveal so let's break it down
for starters it has been confirmed that
the first episode of the wanna vision
series was
in fact filmed in front of a live
audience
really
the series starts with the married witch
and android living in the idyllic town
of
westview we find wanda and vision living
a blissful suburban
existence trying to keep their powers
under wraps but as the newly weds cycle
through the decades and the familiar tv
tropes
they realize their white picket fence
life may not be as
gleamingly picture perfect as it seems
now you have to remember that
with the first teaser that we got for
the one division series they most likely
just showed us the first episode or
first couple of episodes
we know and it's confirmed right here
that the one division series is going to
go through the decades
very very quickly okay paris who's going
to be playing monica rambo said that
this is going to be an
action-packed tv series and we know
we're really not going to get that in
these tv
sitcom type of eras so we're going to go
through and get out of the sitcom errors
pretty quickly as they said
as they cycle through the decades that
means their kids are going to grow up
very fast as well
now another huge thing that has been
revealed by this article that has been
speculated for a very long time is that
we are going to see
wanda fully explore the scarlet witch
and the scarlet
tires yet to be called the scarlet witch
and it has been confirmed they are going
to indeed call her that in the series at
one point and she has yet to discover
her full powers but
then she's going to say i don't want to
call
[Laughter]
scarlet witch comic story lines although
she won't reveal which ones
due to spoilers then it quotes elizabeth
olsen saying it's been the biggest gift
that marvel's given me
getting to do this show you get to just
focus on her
and not how she felt through everyone
else's story lines so it's all about
wanda and the scarlet witch and although
they say they can't reference the comic
book story lines we pretty much know
that a good chunk of the tv series is
going to be based off of the house
and i actually did a video not too long
ago explaining all the comics that one
division is going to be based off of and
i'll link that down below and oh thank
god
what the greatest thing is to see the
scarlet witch i need to know what to buy
i need to know how to spoil the story
for myself
it's really incredible to be able to
tell a long form story the way the
comics did
in a sense a tv show is a multiple issue
comic book run
which is something that from the marvel
development side we totally do
understand
so this is really really cool because in
a way we're going to get a more
comic like tv show than we've ever
gotten before and it was explained in
this ew
article that this is very different from
the netflix marvel shows and
agents of shield because kevin feige had
complete creative control
over these series so this is full mcu
these are basically going to be movies
packed into one hour long episodes
in fact they said six marvel movies says
i was like oh i thought we were doing a
little show
but no six marvel movies packed into
what they're presenting as a sitcom so
disney plus really is giving us marvel
fans a very
unique and awesome opportunity instead
of just getting one two hour film we're
getting
six one hour episodes that's going to be
like six different movies
wow that's gonna be a [ __ ]
reactions ideally
marvel hopes one division will be just
the pilot episode of a long-running tv
dynasty the tokyo is already hard at
work developing
seven additional shows with each one
connecting to past and future
films one division kevin feige notes
just six episodes dr strange in the
multiverse of
madness with olson's witch playing a key
role
alongside benedict cumberbatch sorcerer
and notice how they specifically said
elizabeth olsen's witch that means by
the end of the one division series
leading right up to doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness she is going
to be
a full scarlet witch with her full
powers
so we are definitely in retreat with the
one division series it sounds like it's
going to be
absolutely insane which i love and it
sounds like rwanda is definitely going
to become
one of the most strongest characters in
the entire marvel cinematic universe if
she wasn't already
so let me know what you think about all
these reveals from this ew
article and also of the new photos that
we got as well
let me know in the comments what you're
most excited about for the wanna vision
series don't forget to subscribe studio
audience today
it's marvel news give the video a like
if you enjoyed it and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter
warning this is good so much for
watching let's go we gotta get that
collab going
sucks warren this morning what do you
say
he said yeah he said
that he's got sources oh
on the inside and he gets the download
on everything oh and that everything he
reports on
is coming straight factually from
someone
within the mcu behind the scenes so
someone who's at those marvel
you know yeah studio meetings with kevin
feige and all that yeah
yeah i might have been remembering our
conversation wrong it could have just
been
hey greg when are you available to do
that collab
but i'm pretty sure the conversation
steered in that direction if i'm not
mister there's a bigger fish defense
collapse my friends for the longest time
you know i've thought that scarlet witch
has never truly been able to i mean
she's just been wanda right
so she's never really been able to put
her powers on full display
and before like infinity war came out
amount of people telling me that you
know scarlet witch if they really tapped
into what she's like in the comics she
could take out thanos
and i remember that scene in end game
where she was like
essentially about to destroy thanos
before he was like at least all the
mixes
i think people got very excited about
that not just because of the cathartic
nature
of what thanos did division but because
it was like oh she better
become full scarlet witch here is this
happening at this moment we never
quite got there and it's cool that we're
gonna get something that
solely focuses uh it sounds like it's
definitely way more her show than it is
vision show
vision is gonna be the main supporting
character here while we're really gonna
get this evolution of wanda she's gonna
come into her own as scarlet witch
segway that into doctor strange
multiverse of madness
honestly the biggest takeaway from the
photos would have to be the baby bump
one
everything else was like yeah it's about
everything i've been hearing for the
longest time
these look like stills from scenes where
they're either talking or reacting to
stuff
yeah they're in sitcom world it looks
all peachy
it's a riff on the sitcoms i get it and
then but it's not
as lovely as it appears right i was
taken back by
two things right the fact that this is
gonna be action-packed which for some
reason
surprised me because it's not the vibe
i've gotten from this show at all
it really it really isn't i just said
the back of my mind have to keep
remembering like okay
it's cool he's got wanda and vision yeah
both of those guys could kick a lot of
ass too but i like that they're not
leading with it i was on an impression
this would be kind of the trippy sci-fi
super surreal weird show where falcon
and winter soldier would really take
care of the action yeah
be like the jack ryan type show whereas
this is jack
right that's my touchdown that's what's
really
you know but yeah that kind of thing
where it's like political espionage is
really realistic really gritty and then
this will be the more yeah
surreal trippy whoa what is happening
yeah radical superhero story which
i feel like they still could i like that
idea of both wanda
reaching her full potential in a season
of this show or whatever
and the introduction of potentially
mephisto because it
seems as though that could make like as
much of a bummer as it was at the time
when like end game came out and it's
like oh
scarlet witch didn't really actually hit
that potential i keep hearing people
talk about
maybe with the new shift that the mcu is
going into and the interconnectivity
that they want to provide with this you
know with dr
strange apparently being one of the
major players moving forward it seems
like now might be a better time to have
the fully realized scarlet witch as one
of your you know head players and then
to
further bring you know the underworld
and demons yeah fisto in with that
along with the multiverse of madness
even with its less
horrorness than originally posited it
seems like now is the time and it's
funny because you know
i just moved into season four of ages of
shield and to look at phase four of
marvel it seems like both will have the
similarity of bringing in the hell side
uh which i think is fun and interesting
so yeah i mean i like the idea that
you know this is gonna be a movie
caliber episode each time i sure hope
that it's a really good show and
everybody actually
likes it and stuff that's a cool
prospect and it makes me
excited for all these other things
they're developing but also kind of like
oh my goodness this is a lot you know
and i and i want to
yeah i'm curious to see how they
executed because right now it seems like
there's a lot they're not
showing us which is exciting because you
know lots of surprises
what you're talking about also with the
runtime of it being
six episodes only yeah i think is a
really smart call yeah you know other
than drawing comparisons to netflix
and how they have way too many episodes
and even even with the network
shows they often have way too many
episodes in any of these comic book
shows right keeping it really contained
especially if it has to tie into the
movies directly and if you're expecting
viewers
who watch the movies to also watch
the show and i feel like with what's
going on in the world and how many more
people have not been going to the
theaters and actually watching stuff on
streaming services now
it's a great time to really get the
focus and attention on
the streaming stuff is essential viewing
also if the mephisto
uh storyline is going to be included in
here because a lot of times with comic
book movies and shows they'll like
borrow little things
like oh she's suddenly pregnant it might
not be mephisto it could be given to
another character
she was doing that to her right if it is
him and then they do follow that
storyline where the kids are taken away
that would be really cool that ended on
a really kind of dark note
that ends on a crazy cliffhanger to get
you into multiverse and madness
i would actually love to see something
where it doesn't end on a hero note
and really dark breaking the boundaries
between all the
different universes yeah i think that
would be a really really
cool uh way to conclude all this end it
with a big uh-oh
yeah i think the six-episode release is
is really really smart and
i mean yeah i don't feel like we learned
exactly too many crazy new things out of
this
they they have to they're if anyone's
going to be extra careful it's going to
be these magazine releases they
rarely give you a proof too much
double quadruple approved version of the
target
either way it's probably gonna be a
really fun wild show can't wait to watch
react to it keep a lookout for that
anyway guys what do you think about all
this information released from ew thanks
for award for putting this break down
together
beats reading a whole magazine why would
i do that
subscribe click that notification
subscribe to lauren's channel cosmic
wonder
hit the like button last but not least
maria hammond take it away maria
i wanted to shout you out today because
you know what you seem like someone who
is balancing
the weight of a lot of different
universes and you just want to live in
your
happiness live within your powers and
unlock your true potential and i feel
like that's what i want for you
this year it's maria vision 2020
and i hope that comes without all the
satan babies and stuff like that but
seriously you are the star
of your own sitcom called life you've
lived through a couple decades now at
least so you've got a good perspective
you can mix it up
so uh i'm sending you love and uh please
don't rip the fabric of space-time apart
with uh you know some kind of outfit
very good i think maria will
really appreciate that i love this her
last name is hammond hammond
which is like jojo's bizarre adventure
oh yeah which i
i don't think she watches but you know
channeling the life
you breathe yeah and that's a lot
similar to like you know what witches
can do too
and so like yeah channel your inner
inner inner
yeah well you know cause the elements
and you know wick uh but that's not the
same
she's a good witch witch
the only good witch is a white witch
glinda you're you're let's just mix
every which property
[Music]
you